[Music]
i think we tend to not see conscious
experiences for what they
are at a very basic level pleasure pain
visual or auditory experience these are
all forms
of consciousness and so we need to
consider the brain and the body and in
the world
but i can't change the world by just
imagining it to be
different otherwise it would be
different right now
[Music]
want to start by clearing up a little
bit of ambiguity the word consciousness
is
is a very ambiguous word often people
use it to mean
something quite sophisticated like
self-consciousness
awareness of one's own existence this is
something quite sophisticated that we
might be reluctant to ascribe to many
non-human animals
it's not clear a rabbit is aware of its
own existence
but all that i'm going to mean you know
all that's generally meant in these
discussions
by the word consciousness it's probably
a little bit of a misleading word really
all it really means is experience
pleasure pain visual or auditory
experience these are all forms
of consciousness so consciousness in
this sense is certainly
something where we'd be happy to ascribe
quite generally
in the animal kingdom whether or not a
rabbit is aware of its own existence
it certainly has experiences if you're
cruel enough to put a knife in a rabbit
it's going to feel pain so i don't think
it's difficult to define what we mean by
consciousness
the challenge the problem of
consciousness is how consciousness fits
into our scientific worldview
despite great progress in our scientific
understanding of the brain
we still don't really have even the
beginnings of an explanation
of how complicated electrochemical
signaling
is somehow able to give rise to an inner
subjective
world of colors and sounds and smells
and tastes
that each of us knows every second of
waking life
so this is the profound challenge
consciousness poses to the sciences
now it's although it's broadly agreed
that there is a profound challenge here
uh one very common reaction is to say
okay there's a problem but we just need
to
plug away with our standards methods of
investigating the brain just do a little
bit more neuroscience maybe cognitive
science and we'll crack it
one thing i'm keen to press in my work
as a philosopher of consciousness
is upon reflection it turns out this is
isn't just another scientific problem in
many ways this is
the problem of consciousness is
absolutely unique among scientific
problems
and in fact that the standard tools of
invite scientific investigation
are not really equipped to deal with it
at least not entirely
there are two traditional options here
on the one hand dualism the view that
consciousness is non-physical
outside of the physical workings of the
body in the brain
and on the other hand materialism
roughly the view that consciousness can
be explained in terms of the chemistry
of the brain
the electrochemical signalings in the
brain
unfortunately and this is really why the
problem of consciousness is so hard
is that both of these familiar options
face quite profound and much discussed
challenges so i'll just give you
a taste of the difficulties with these
options
the problem of dualism is that
neuroscience seems to show no sign of
the impact of an immaterial mind
so although jewelers think the mind and
the brain are separate
they think they stand in a close causal
relationship if the
if the uh the soul the immaterial mind
wants the arm to go up it makes change
in the brain the arms go up
uh my material mind wants to express
express my thoughts as i'm speaking to
you it makes changes in the brain
my lips move sound comes out
now if there was an immaterial mind
impacting on the brain every second of
waking life
you'd think that would really show up in
on neuroscience there'd be all
sorts of things happening in the brain
that had no
physical explanation it would be like a
poltergeist was playing with the brain
and that's not what we seem to find he's
i've just finished a popular article for
um bbc future and
here's why i try to explain it there
that might be helpful the relationship
between the
the mind and the brain for a duelist is
a bit like the relationship between
a drone pilot and his or her drone
right you you receive information from
the drone from the sensors of the drone
and you control it
similarly uh you know uh for the duelist
you receive information from your brain
and you control your body via your brain
now if you were to examine the physical
workings of a drone
in principle you could see where the
radio signals come into the drone
and the pilot controls it similarly if
dualism is true you'd think
by examining the brain we'd see where
the the signals were coming in from the
immaterial mind
rene descartes perhaps the most famous
duelist in history hypothesized that it
happened in the pineal gland
which is a real um p-shaped gland in the
in
in towards the center of the brain
between the two hemispheres
but neuroscience reveals that there
isn't really such a special place in the
brain
and indeed everything that happens in
the brain seems to be caused by other
physical processes in the brain
so it's rather like if we um suppose we
found something we thought was a drone
and then we examined it and we
discovered actually everything that it's
doing is
caused by physical processes within it
then we draw the conclusion
actually this isn't a drone at all it's
a robot many philosophers and scientists
would like to draw something like that
conclusion
about the human brain okay so these kind
of considerations push
a lot of people to materialism
what's the problem of materialism well
here that
here i think we come back to galileo
since galileo physical science has
worked with a purely
quantitative vocabulary whereas
consciousness
is an essentially quality involving
phenomenon if you think about
the smell of coffee the feel of cold ice
the blueness of a blue experience
and as galileo well understood you can't
capture these kind of
qualities in the purely quantitative
vocabulary of physical science
and so as long as your description of
the brain
is framed in the purely quantitative
vocabulary
of neuroscience you're always going to
leave out these qualities
and hence leave out consciousness itself
so i mean i think the philosophical case
against materialism
is very compelling um
as more and more people are accepting
why does dualism
why does materialism still be still seen
to be probably just about the most
popular option
i think it's because of a certain kind
of inference people draw from the
history of science they think
look at the great success of physical
science you know and explaining more and
more of our universe
producing incredible technology you know
the wonders of technology has this kind
of visceral effect on you
and this leads people think well of
course it's one day going to explain
consciousness
but i think this common reaction is
rooted in a misunderstanding of the
history of science
yes physical science has been incredibly
successful but it's been incredibly
successful precisely because
galileo designed it to exclude
consciousness
if galileo were to time travel to the
present day and hear about this
difficulty of explaining consciousness
in the terms of physical science he'd
say
of course you can't do that i designed
physical science to deal with the
quantitative not the qualitative right
and you know
the reason it's been so successful is
that i gave it this very narrow
focused task and the fact that it's been
very good at dealing with the
quantitative
doesn't give you grounds to think it's
going to be good dealing with a quite
different explanatory task of dealing
with these
subjective qualities we find in
[Music]
experience
well i think of consciousness as um a
feature or property of certain mental
mental occurrences mental episodes
thoughts
feelings sensations conscious
sexual experiences and these are
properties ultimately of living
organisms
and they are determined by what's going
on in
inside the organism and what's going on
outside the organism some combination of
those
those things um does that mean that
consciousness
is physical and well here i have to turn
into a philosopher and i say well
i'm sorry but that depends what you mean
by physical the
the idea that consciousness might be
physical has been tied
to the doctrine of physicalism
um which is a kind of inheritor
of the 17th century notion of
materialism
the idea that everything is matter
everything is made of matter
um um physicalism says something
slightly different because it says that
it ties it stopped to physics
and physical science as physics strictly
speaking
and i don't think there's any reason to
think that consciousness
is physical in that sense that its
physical science is going to tell us
what the nature of consciousness is
and i think consciousness is a feature
that um
of the states of living beings and
not inanimate beings inanimate beings
don't have consciousness
you have to be living to have
consciousness and i
take that to be obvious i know some
people object to the
to this but um you know people are going
to object
so what i want to say is that that's
consciousness is not physical in the
sense that
physicalism or materialism says that
everything is physical
nonetheless consciousness is i think a
property or feature of
organisms which are material objects in
the sense that they have material
properties and
qualities and things like that well that
doesn't tell you anything about how to
explain consciousness or how to
understand it
it's just getting clear on the basic
issue of whether you should think
consciousness is something physical
i think consciousness is something
psychological and the psychological
comes from
emerges out of the biological in a way
that we don't understand
and but that's
my appeal to the idea of emergence there
is is serious because i think that there
are there are
some stages in the evolution of the
world and the
evolution of organisms where um new
things generally come into existence and
whether or not we can understand how
those things came into existence
is an open question
[Music]
um well if the question is uh how far
can we understand consciousness from
looking at the brain
a brain on its own is not enough we need
a brain
the job of the brain after all is to
control its body along with the rest of
the nervous system
and so we need to consider the brain and
the body
and in the world that's definitely the
way things are moving within
consciousness studies
but i want to pick on a particular
problem that i think is is very evident
in those
scientists who are really trying to use
neuroscience
and brain scans and so on um to
to understand consciousness very popular
is the idea of looking for the neural
correlates of consciousness
and this idea started with francis crick
back in his famous 1994 book
the astonishing hypothesis can sum up
the astonishing hypothesis as
you're just a bunch of neurons just a
pack of neurons
um and of course people don't really
like that idea
but he made the very sensible statement
that
i mean after all he'd solved the dna
problem and all that you know
if you're going to go into a new science
and he thought he could solve the
consciousness problem as well
you're going to go into new science you
start with correlations before moving on
to
try and understand causes so hence
started the idea of looking for the
neural correlates of consciousness
a classic example in this paradigm is a
sort of experiment where you can take
people
or even other species
and have something like um you know a
neckar cube where it flips
you can see it looking this way or it
flips and it looks the other way
or the famous duck rabbit where it's
rabbit and
duck um and it's impossible
for you to see both at once so the idea
would be well when i'm conscious of the
duck
as opposed to the rabbit what's going on
in my brain
can i do a brain scan or eeg or
something like that
and if i could see which bits are
changing i'd have found
consciousness the bit of the brain that
gives rise to consciousness
and they've been lots of experiments
like that and they tend to find all
different bits of the brain
are the answer to what flips when your
conscious visions
flips and don't seem to be quite getting
to the answer but they keep looking
i think it's completely the wrong
approach because
as philip has kind of hinted at it's
it's kind of hidden dualism the basis
here is that
the brain gives rise to consciousness
consciousness is something other than or
more than the activity of the brain
so we've got to find consciousness
itself and where it is in the brain
which bring processes give rise to it
and so on
now dualism just doesn't work and most
people
would agree with that and you've heard
something about it already
so this dualistic view goes in line with
thinking that the hard problem is real
again you've heard about the phrase the
hard problem
also appeared in 1994 when the uh then
young
australian philosopher um uh
dave chalmers contrasted it with the
easy problems the hard problem of
consciousness itself
but the easy problems of perception
learning memory and so on
that's the same kind of mindset that
makes you look for consciousness itself
being generated by the brain and makes
people ask well
um when did it arise what does
consciousness do
uh why did what's the function when did
it evolve and so on
i think all of that is completely
misguided
and there are alternatives there's pan
psychism but
you may have made it sound like that's
one thing and it's not there are lots
and lots of versions of pan psychism we
may get to some of those
there's illusionism now both nick and i
were
have have chapters in a book called
illusionism and you refuse to use the or
don't like using the word illusion
i would say consciousness is a big
illusion
in the sense we've got it completely
wrong right from
young childhood um children start to
distinguish between living and
non-living thinking and not thinking
conscious and not conscious and not far
behind it's very natural to us to
imagine that
i do some things consciously and i do
and i others
unconsciously i see some things
consciously some others are
subliminal and so on and from there to
think there are some processes in the
brain
that are conscious processes and others
that are unconscious
it's just so easy to think that way i
think all of that is wrong
i think that consciousness is something
we attribute to some parts of what we're
doing or some things we see
after the fact we're completely deluded
about it
we will in the end find some kind of
possibly pan psychic some kind of answer
but i think what we should be doing is
looking in the brain
and looking in our evolutionary story
for what it was
that made us so deluded that we might
find
but consciousness itself i would say we
never will
because there's no such thing
[Music]
might the very distinction between
subject
and object conscious experience and the
world be
the mistake it's a very loaded question
even the two ways
in which you ask the question and have
two different meanings right
i think there is a sense in which the
distinction between
self and world is an empirical fact that
is undeniable
so in what sense is that the case well i
have some degree of control over the
imagery in my imagination
but i can't change the world by just
imagining it to be
different otherwise it would be
different right now
um so there is a sense in which that
distinction
is undeniable it's an empirical datum of
existence
and then you can go down the question
you know is this
metaphysically speaking a fundamental
distinction
or is this an illusion we can pursue
those paths but i don't think the core
of the problem is whether there is a
subject separate from us from an object
i think the core of the problem
are the metaphysical assumptions we make
when we talk about a subject when we
talk about
a object what do we mean by these words
um to name two examples a materialist
would deny the distinction and i would
agree with the materialist there i don't
think there is any
fundamental distinction between subject
and object
but a materialist would make that
assumption that
the objects the world out there are
exhaustively describable through
quantities
in other words if you come up with the
right list of numbers
then you say everything there is to be
said about the object
and then because they don't distinguish
the subject from the object the same has
to apply to the subject
so then you face that situation in which
my inner life
has to be exhaustively describable by a
list of numbers
and i know for a fact that it isn't
because my inner life is constituted of
qualities
not only quantities now a penn psychist
could say well
i will make a a a different assumption i
will say that there
are fundamental boundaries between the
subjectivity inside
and the objectivity outside and i will
say that those boundaries are the
boundaries of
the primary elements of the material
world whatever they might be
so you're basically saying you're
basically acknowledging the distinction
between object and subject at a
fundamental level
but then you run into another problem
because of one's metaphysical
assumptions and that is
well if i have good reason to think i am
fundamentally separate from the world
out there
then by the same token the left
hemisphere of my brain is fundamentally
separate from the right
actually by the same token one neuron is
fundamentally separate from the next
neuron
one atom from the next one subatomic
particle from the next
and then you have to explain why our
inner lives feel
unitary because that's how we experience
it our inner lives
so to summarize and conclude my answer i
don't think the core
of the problem is the question is the
subject distinct from the object because
there is a sense in which it's obvious
obviously is
and fundamentally it probably is not but
the problem is
the metaphysical assumptions we make
when we talk about these things
[Music]
and yeah so so let me just um
briefly say i guess that i don't think
that in
reality that is at a fundamental level
there is this subject object dichotomy
um i think the notion of subject comes
directly out of the illusion
of self which is created by the brain
and i think the experience of self comes
largely out of the function of memory
although there are many different types
of brain processing
at play that i think contribute to this
illusion um and so i think we tend to
not see conscious experiences for what
they
are at a very basic level um which i
would say is qualia or felt experience
that appear in the universe rather than
qualia that appear
to a subject in the universe which i
think is an additional
um and false step and way of of seeing
things
um so the combination of qualia through
memory and across time creates this
illusion
that there's a solid self moving through
time
that again certain conscious experiences
are appearing too
but i think that's part of the illusion
and that this illusion contaminates a
lot if not most of our thinking about
consciousness
um so in contemplating theories that
place consciousness at a fundamental
level which is something i'm very open
to and interested in
i consider it to be a red flag when i
see the use of
subject or the concept of of subject
embedded in the theory
and that if we're going to consider
consciousness as fundamental i think we
need to look at
a qualia or felt experience um more like
bubbles in a pot of boiling water where
consciousness
itself is pervasive so consciousness is
the water in that analogy
um so i just think it's important to
question how we're thinking about or
using
concepts like subject and self
um and privacy is is another term that
comes up in this context
and to just keep a close eye on how
we're using these concepts or how
they're guiding
or rather misguiding our thinking for
more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of arts and ideas at iai tv